passez à l'interview pinceaux avec
d'hélico quand on parle peinture sans
bavure ses lunettes noires le samedi
soir catégorie arts plastiques
voici donc la dîmière velits comique
or la demi-heure velickovic bonsoir tu
es né en 1935 à belgrade et a commencé à
dessiner tout seul à l'âge de 7 ans
c'est vrai ça
[Applaudissements]
et
comme tous les enfants oui comme tous
les ans toutes unités durèrent
michel-ange quand même non pas sept ans
mais plus tard je me suis un peu
ni à bien regarder attentivement et
d'essayer de copier comme
ça se doit tu as fait ta première expo à
l'âge de 16 ans c'est ça c'était ma
première participation officielle
ouais à 16 ans et à 65
tu as fait ta première exposition à
l'étranger à bruxelles ensuite la même
année et a représenté la yougoslavie à
la biennale de paris
c'est venu à paris pour cinq mois et ça
fait quand même temps que la bave 1 525
7 jours c'est à dire c'était une venue
du prix le jeu gagne à cette même veine
le prix c'était la bourse suis venu pour
pour faire cette boucle
et puis
c'est resté vous en une sorte de séjour
temporaire prolonger leur état dans les
quelque chose
alors si pour mathis la peinture comme
on dit et enfin comme ils disent et un
fauteuil confortable
c'est pas vraiment ton cas et pour moi
c'est un portait plainte des pin
ouais quand on voit ce que tu fais
d'ailleurs ce qui est très très amusant
c'est ton personnage comme ça
relativement sweat et quand on voit les
tableaux que tu fais c'est vrai qu'à une
distance et nos ordres alors tu as
toujours pas un homme nu vaguement
anthropoïdes comme ça soit sur des
escaliers escalier qui vont nulle part
qui viennent de nulle part
soit en chute libre dans l'espace est
finalement un peu l'homme aux prises
avec son destin que l'on peut vous dire
d'une façon un peu grisâtre his way et
tu n'es jamais sorti de sa comment ça se
fait partout jour et nuit va voir
onu quelqu'un disait que les vêtements
c'est la caricature du corps oui
pourtant laissé ce corps dans son état
brut que
clair net et 13 ans et travaille avec
parce que pour moi il était toujours
plus intéressant de voir comment
bouchain muscles de mon bout j'ai dit
oui vrai le fait avec lui ça peut être
une merveille suffit de voir le dessin
de générer d'autres pour se rendre
compte
peut-être même plus difficile à dessiner
mais le lieu pour moi c'est comme une
sorte de d'unités de de base
sept corps nus tel rôle dans la plupart
des cas même dans la rue ni vert rouge
noir guillou sa détente assombri
ensanglanté il ya des constantes l
étalon et les crochets il ya les cordes
pourquoi ça commence a été amené à
réduire l'univers assez assez quelques
symboles comme ça bon avec avec
le corps et ses accessoires j'ai
construit un alphabet dieu qui m'a pris
avec cette même richesse d'information
de construire
une image mais plusieurs images mais de
construire et de dire ce que je pense
d'eux dans une certaine activité de
l'homme d'affaires comportement c'est à
dire de base et les intérêts sur ceux
qui l agressivité violence du destin 6 à
10 ans dont on alphabet comme tu dis il
ya aussi des chiens des rapaces et des
rats beaucoup de rats parce que tu dit
leur art c'est un peu ce qui restera
quand tu auras plus 2
c'est ça qui était si je pense que
chaque chaque peintre
à son petit vestiaire mon bestiaire été
concernant les oiseaux les oiseaux avec
agressif c'est à dire les maires à ce
niveau pour les aigles d'ailleurs ils
sont toujours d'actualité parce que je
travaille quand même un peu actuellement
avec des textes des chaussures ça bon il
y avait les chiens qui ont concouru ils
ont couru plusieurs plusieurs tours et
puis son arrêté parce que j'ai trouvé
que là il y avait un danger qui m'a
inquiété
c'est à dire d'une transformer en
peintre animalier toujours des visages
de tête broyée des visages et corps
chaud en voit rarement le visage de ses
hommes
ben la tête ce n'était pas mon problème
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais fait un portrait
je suis complètement infirme de ce côté
là je peux pas te décides c'est parti et
j'ai envie beaucoup de gens qui ont
croître et il te donne cette une
c'est un talent une capacité c'est un
art à part mais mais mais peut-être pour
moi c'était toujours quelque chose d
anonymes m peut broyer un peu avec cette
bouche ouverte en train de
de lire des shows et la percée court un
peu de porter un certain jugement sur
tout ce qui est orateurs les pins qui
doit influencer ce qui peut-être
influencé par barbouch par caen bc le
problème d'influencé difficile à évoquer
à situer je sais que mes amours
de l'époque de la jeunesse de démettre
de mes débuts était tout ce qui était
doté d'un
un côté un peu fantastique un peu sur
réalisant même tu disais bosch
il y avait brel il y avait les primitifs
du nord vous avez toute cette peinture
avec dürer et sa stabilité son dessin
très très très bien
mais
c'était c'était là où j'ai essayé
d'apprendre et puis je me rends compte
qu'avec le temps avec l'expérience avec
tout ce qui se passe je commence un peu
à décembre vers le sud vers tout ce qui
est la renaissance italienne même la
très renaissance j'ai une très forte
fascination pour le dire de la françe
scarponi ita/and par exemple et d'autre
part
j'ai une passion pour les icônes
orthodoxes c'est à dire bonjour en fait
je l'aï bien je deviens tu tournes à
mazamet source byzance renaissance c'est
quelque chose qui est lié qui a quelque
chose de commun je finis par te trouver
j'aimerais j'aimerais on peut les voir
ou ans commenté tableau les tableaux en
permanence
j'expose chez patrice trigano puis il ya
des choses qui circulent un peu plus
facilement gens résistants demain à la
une par exemple qu'il ya certains
ouvrages sur moi qu'ils sont
les spécialisées il y aura probablement
une manifestation concernant les
sculptures que j'ai découvert récemment
dans une galerie de strasbourg s'appelle
me connu que ça sert à quoi est ce que
tu fais ton avis ça sert à quoi
à quoi ça sert la peinture de l'école et
je me suis jamais posé la question si ça
sert à quelque chose
en dehors de moi maintenant allez
peut-être une attitude qui est qui est
un peu
inhabituel mais quand je fais quelque
chose c'est anthony deux cas c'est que
ça se passe et j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
envisagé pendant le travail de penser
que ça doit servir à quelque chose ça
doivent faire plaisir à quelqu'un ça m'a
vraiment ça m'intéresse
question rituelle s'il fallait donner
une définition de toi ce serait quoi
bah
m bagarre et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu